I of course caught a lot of heat
yesterday from the Bengal fans and read
some of their tweets some of the tweets
that I could read you know Joe Burrell
came on the show at the Super Bowl and
you know we talked about going number
one and the Bengals and is that one in
the same where you're going to a team B
you know you're going number one but you
want to go to a team that's committed to
winning you know Carson Palmer talked
about the Bengals aren't committed to
winning Super Bowls his brother Jordan
is working out jobber oh and I thought
Joe was a little bit vague on the
Bengals okay let me let me just play the
clip here is Joe burrow that'll put it
in context do you want to hear from the
bengals of whenever you're in the
conversation for the number one pick
it's obviously a dream come true but
they I know they have a process to go
through I have a process to go through
so that's it's a long ways away but it
is being number one or going to the
right team the most important to
combination of both you know you want to
go number one but you also want to go to
a great organization that's committed to
winning committed to winning Super Bowls
all right let me bring in Mike Florio
from Pro Football Talk Mike thanks for
joining us what are you hearing that
comment from Joe Burrell
well I hear that at some level he is
influenced by Carson Palmer and how
could you not be the threads are right
in front of us Carson Palmer says the
bengals aren't committed to winning a
Super Bowl he quit on the bengals he
quote-unquote retired until the
opportunity came to trade him to the
Raiders after Jason Campbell broke her
collarbone back in 2011 it all worked
out just perfectly and the Bengals got a
good return but he was done he was not
going to play anymore because he was
frustrated with the Bengals lack of
effort to try to win a Super Bowl
Jordan Palmer's brother is training Joe
burrow it doesn't take many steps to get
to the point where all of a sudden Joe
burrow is saying those things like I
want to play for a team that's committed
to winning and Dan I'm a firm believer
and this is a take that becomes less and
less popular every year but I really
don't care I don't like the draft I
don't like the fact that these guys are
forced to go live in a certain city play
for a certain team they get to pick
their college I don't and it's turned
into this it's an honor it's not an
honor it's not you don't get to pick
where you start
NFL career and for some of these
quarterbacks I think that that getting
picked by a bad organization keep you
from ever becoming the guy you could
have been I say all the time in 1999 if
Donna McNabb didn't pick by the Bengals
and a Kelly Smith them and picked by the
Eagles how different would those two
careers have gone we don't know but I
think it's a factor and I think that
especially when you are a guy like Joe
burrow and you are at the top of the
stack I like it when the guy takes a
stand and says I don't want to play for
the team that has the first pick like
Eli Manning did like John Elway did I
think it needs to happen more often and
you had some quotes in your column on
pro football talk comm where you know we
heard from his dad Jimmy borough Joe's
dad so he texts somebody at Fox 19 in
Cincinnati not sure where that
information is coming from Jimmy burrows
said we're all excited that Joe has put
himself in a position to be considered
as a possible high draft choice all
right well that doesn't say anything
about it here's the problem here's the
problem and and this is I think driven
by the way that fans react to players
who buck the system right
we applaud owners when they make savvy
business deals that result in more
billions being piled on top of the
billions they have so they can buy a 250
million dollar yacht and be titans of
industry when players try to make
business decisions fans get mad fans
think players should just submit to the
process you get drafted you happily go
there and the reality is and and you
know people who know Mike Brown firmly
believe if he wants Joe Burrell
he's taken Joe burrow and if Joe burrow
don't like it tough crap Joe burrow sit
out the whole year and reenter the draft
so it could be that these maneuverings
if there are any that are going to
happen
fail and you got to go to Cincinnati and
if you have to choose between going to
Cincinnati or sitting out the year maybe
you just bite the bullet and go to
Cincinnati and you don't want the fans
to hate you walking through the door I
think that's why they're being vague
about it they don't want to come out and
say we don't want Cincinnati because in
the end they may have no choice but also
you have TJ Houshmandzadeh who played
with the Bengals he's working with
jobber a wide receiver
and he said hey we're not disparaging
the Bengals but then he did say that
they should strongly consider any
gigantic train offer hey my god what hey
Dan I can tell you this and I don't like
the traffic in pre-draft rumor and smoke
screens because there's agendas and and
you know there's always a motivation to
try to get something out there and and
and I'm always skeptical about the
things I hear but every once in a while
you hear something that under the
circumstances given the time context
given the source you can take it to the
bank take this to the bank Stephen Ross
the owner of the dolphins wants Joe
burrow and I assume that has gotten back
to Joe burrow so Miami and the Dolphins
Cincinnati and the Bengals if there's a
way you can work it that you get to
Miami maybe that's the better choice and
that's why they keep it vague because
you don't know if a team wants to go up
and get you and the Dolphins have the
draft capital you know I asked Todd
McShea yesterday I said if you're Joe
burrow would you rather go to Cincinnati
or Miami right now given the state of
those organizations he said Miami what
do you think Miami oh look look you know
some of the folks in Cincinnati are
getting upset the national media is
making this a thing but let's be fair
about it if you got to choose between
Cincinnati and pretty much any other
team right now
sorry Bengals but I'm picking the other
team right unless it's a team that has a
franchise quarterback that's going to be
starting for years to come like the
Chiefs but all things being equal I
don't want to play for the Bengals i
agree with carson palmer's assessment
what why would carson palmer be lying
about this he lived it from 2003 through
2010 so yeah I I defer to that and it
meshes with everything I've always heard
about Mike Brown and the Bengals that
it's not about winning championships
it's about making money and they make a
ton of money and they don't spend a lot
of money it's a profitable business
period and some owners look at it that
way and some are less discreet than
others about you know letting it be
known that that is the motivation not
winning championships it's not gonna
Mike Florio co-host a pro football talk
with Chris Simms on the NBC Sports
Network
the Jags with another game in London and
the Jacksonville fans always get upset
with me where I just say hey hold on for
dear life man because now you got an
owner saying hey I can make money in
London and that helps me in building
this whatever this community around the
stadium and all these big plans he has
business-wise at what point do you think
that they only do one game in London or
they add a third game in London what
happens first with the Jags oh I think
it may go back to one game next year I
think that this really is an experiment
right let's see how it goes let's see
how two games with the same team there
goes because I had somebody who who was
in London reach out to me and say look
when I go to a Jaguars game 25% of the
fans are Jaguars fans the other people
just football fans fans me the other
team fans of any team they just want to
go to a game I don't know how much of a
fan base the Jaguars can build but I
think the vision for Schad con would be
remember how the Packers used to split
their schedule between County Stadium in
Milwaukee and Lambeau Field
I could see four games in Jacksonville
four games in London
make the playoffs host a game you don't
have to worry about all the extra
logistics of taking teams to London to
play a playoff game and you got to turn
around the team the road team wins have
to fly back across the ocean and maybe
play a game in California I mean it
would get ridiculous Jacksonville's your
home base if you host playoff games
you're still the Jacksonville Jaguars
you play half your games in London and I
wouldn't be surprised in at some point
if there are two teams that do that so
yeah yeah the two stadiums you split
your schedule between your us base and
London I think that makes sense
otherwise too many logistical problems
too many hurdles too many hardships for
players if they're if they're I would
all I would much prefer to moving a team
to London this concept of having up to
eight games with different teams I think
that's the better approach but if
anybody's going to establish that base
there it would be the Jaguars playing
half their games I think that's where it
ends up the 17 game NFL regular season
schedule I'm not sure where we stand on
this and I know the players are gonna
vote on this or the the union's gonna
vote on this but how do you think that
vote would would play out if I said to
you know the entire NFL player base
you guys want to play a 17-game schedule
and you'll get an extra game check well
it's got to be more than an extra game
check to play an extra game there's got
to be a premium there and it can't just
be extra salary cap space because then
the stars get that money the minimums
have to go up you have to ensure that
that money is going to make its way to
the average player who is out there
grinding week in and week out here's
what's happening Dan and this is in a
nutshell where things stand the Union
and the league have negotiated a deal
they have a deal you have to sell the
deal to your client though and it's like
a lawsuit you settle a lawsuit the
lawyers work out a deal and then they go
sell to do to their clients the NFLPA is
trying to sell the deal to its client
the problem is the NFLPA is getting
unexpected pushback from the client and
so there hasn't been a vote yet because
they did a vote they're afraid it would
be no so they're trying to work this
through and here's the reality here's
what the union has to ask itself will we
take a work stoppage lockout or strike
and actually miss game checks if you
won't miss game checks and football
games then why take the best deal on the
brink of missing game checks when you
can take the best deal now at a time
when that can be parlayed into new TV
deals that are done before the
presidential election hurts ratings
before our session which is being
expected by the folks behind the curtain
who are counting the money for the NFL
before the budgets getting pinched
because of that they want to turn this
around now I think Dee Smith understands
when push comes to shove these guys are
going to take 17 games because they're
not going to miss game checks to take a
stand so let's just do it now and then
let's get billions more on these TV
deals that will be negotiated
immediately after this is done that's
when you got to sell these guys on and
he hasn't been able to do it yet final
question the most interesting offseason
quarterback storyline is without
question where does hashtag Tommy go
where does he go right cuz I think look
Dan in New England he's only going back
if Bill Belichick gets on a knee and
applies his lips to the butt cheeks each
side of Tom Brady he's sick of dealing
with being beaten down by this guy for
20 years Bill Belichick is who he is
he wants some appreciation some
acknowledgement some recognition without
that I think he's 11 and we were
throwing this around today on PFT live
because Sims knows Kyle Shanahan really
well and you know I'm of the mindset
that Kyle Shanahan needs to be thinking
about potential upgrades at the
quarterback position because
championship quarterback to make
championship throws and Garoppolo had
one that he could have made and he
didn't if you're Shanahan and you pick
up your cell phone and it's Tom Brady
and he says I'd really like to come play
for the team that I rooted for growing
up I think that with me we can win
championship this year what do you say
if you're Kyle Shanahan what do you say
to that what do you say I I'd be tempted
to say yes if I work I'll change do you
think that the Niners would have won the
Super Bowl with Tom Brady yes okay
without question okay don't you yes I do
I just don't know because Belichick
would love to get Garoppolo back right
wouldn't that be something
I don't know I don't know if a Bella
checks all enough where he goes now you
know on second thought now I'll let you
keep Garoppolo in San Francisco hey Dan
in all seriousness seriousness no the
way that the 49ers structure these
contracts they have until April 1 to
make a decision on Garoppolo that's an
eternity in the NFL offseason you can
wait to see what plays out with Brady
you can wait to see what other free
agents are out there you can you could
maybe make the subtle phone call to the
Vikings and say hey you know if you're
not going to extend Kirk Cousins we'll
take him here Kyle Shanahan said last
week the reason he didn't evaluate
Patrick Holmes in 2017 is he was certain
he was going to get Kirk Cousins in free
agency a year later and that's the other
thing they could do they give Garoppolo
one more year and then go get Kirk
Cousins if he doesn't sign an extension
in Minnesota I'm telling you look yeah
Garoppolo is the weak link on that team
and and 49ers fans get upset it's like
folks you should want your team to get
better and if there's a better option
out there at quarterback why don't you
want it well I don't know if it would
ever happen but it's fun talking about
it it wouldn't be great would it be
great it would be great I root for chaos
right it keeps it keeps us occupied oh
ok did you like the offseason better
than the regular season oh we make we
got more traffic make more money in the
offseason I mean that's because that
because there's no football so it's just
rumor and dynamic speculation yeah
ball fans when you don't have a light
every week you're constantly trying to
check in to see what happens so yeah we
will have our biggest month of the year
in March and then in April and then even
in May June and July when people don't
have their football fix they go look for
whatever they can get great to talk to
you again Mike thank you as always
that's Mike Florio Pro Football Talk
for more game Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]